immer wieder explosionen feuer im
berliner grunewald ausgerechnet auf
einem sprengplatz der polizei war es in
der nacht ausgebrochen hier lagert auf
und munition für kontrollierte
sprengungen schwierige lage für die
feuerwehr es kommt doch weiterhin zu
massiven explosionen die man im
hintergrund hört der brand konnte sich
auch aufgrund der trockenen vegetation
schnell auf das umliegende waldgebiet
ausbreiten die erst eintreffenden
einsatzkräfte müssten sich aber auch in
folge schnell zurückziehen da eine
natürlich eine große gefahr auch von den
weiteren explosionen und kampfmitteln
des springplatzes ausgeht hoher
rauchwolken waren noch in weiten teilen
des berliner westens zu sehen
mittlerweile sind auch wasserwerfer und
hubschrauber vor ort doch bisher können
die feuerwehrleute noch nicht zum
brandherd vordringen müssen sich darauf
beschränken das feuer daran zu hindern
sich weiter auszubreiten gegen halb vier
heute morgen kam der erste alarm nach
einer explosion auf dem sprengplatz
hatten flammen auf den angrenzenden wald
übergegriffen
die lage ist enorm außergewöhnlich einen
sprengplatz munition kampfmitteln und
feuerwerkskörpern hat erhebliche
gefahren unsere ersten einsatzkräfte die
heute morgen um 33 tätig geworden sind
mussten sich zurückziehen denen sind
trümmerteile um die köpfe führung gewann
in höchster lebensgefahr
der schienenverkehr auf einer nahen
bahnlinie ist unterbrochen ebenso auch
auf der autobahn abos anwohner sind
bisher nicht gefährdet vor ort ist meine
kollegin stephanie heim guten tag
offenbar kommt es immer wieder zu
explosionen und die feuerwehr kann nicht
so richtig löschen wie ist denn die lage
jetzt vor ort
die lage ist da wo es tatsächlich brennt
immer noch sehr unübersichtlich weil die
feuerwehr da eben nicht rein kann es ist
jetzt gerade ein roboter der bundeswehr
hier eingetroffen denn den mann
ferngesteuert mit vier kameras
ausgerüstet in das brandgebiet rein
lassen kann um zu gucken wo genau ist
eigentlich brennt und was da eigentlich
ist das auch ein bergepanzer hier
angekommen der auch mit aufräumen kann
also ist die bundeswehr hier die
feuerwehr mit mindestens 120 menschen
die polizei ist jedes technische
hilfswerk die sich alle darum kümmern
wollen es ist ein sperrkreis um die
diesen sprengplatz eingerichtet von 1000
metern da geht es darum dass wenn da
noch mal was detoniert eben nichts raus
fliegt es sind keine anwohner betroffen
das hat auch die in senatorin hier
gerade noch mal gesagt das ist alles in
sicherheit die autobahn ist immer noch
gesperrt die ist ja über mir da kommen
wir gleich mal gucken das sieht man
nämlich genau da oben dass man nichts
sieht auf der autobahn fährt schon seit
stunden nichts mehr seit heute morgen
dahinter liegt eine bahnlinie die ist
auch immer noch geschlossen und das wird
vermutlich auch noch eine ganze weile so
da ist so seien es also eine ganze weile
dauern denn es bevor nicht auf diesen
schwenk platz wirklich dass die geguckt
haben was da passiert und das alles
gelöscht ist man nach brandnestern
geschaut hat wird hier auch nichts
wieder geöffnet werden es liegen hier
wohl an die 25 tonnen munition
das ist vor allem in sachen die hier bei
baustellen in berlin gefunden werden da
kommen jeden tag zwei oder drei
neuzugänge die dann da gelagert werden
das macht diesen diesen brand hier so
gefährlich ist es gar nicht die aus das
sind ja nicht die ausmaße des feuers was
hier brennt und die einsatzkräfte gehen
auch nicht davon aus dass sich das weit
darüber hinaus noch verbreiten wird aber
was innerhalb dieses springplatzes
passiert das weiß eben noch keiner so
genau und das macht die lage so
unübersichtlich live vor ort stefanie
hahn vielen dank für ihre einschätzung